hey guys what's up this is andrew for
10senses.com so in this video guys i
would like to make a big update on
gamestop we finally had a close above
the major resistance trendline so let's
get into it
[Music]
oh right guys so it's looking very good
but it's not perfect so let me go
through everything that happened on
friday let's try to understand why we
had this move up
and what it means right now in terms of
technicals are we bullish are we bearish
of course we are bullish on the medium
term but let's analyze exactly what is
happening in the short term what might
happen this week and the week after that
uh we're gonna go through the option
market check the dtc check the 950
strike so we're going to have a look at
basically everything and try to
anticipate what will happen so first you
guys know this chart
i'm here using basic technical analysis
tools like trend lines i am in a
logarithmic scale just for you to see
the difference if you're not using the
log scale you can't see the strength
line
so you have another trendline that you
can make that gave you a reaction as
well but basically the reactions you're
gonna have using the logarithmic scale
are gonna be more reliable on more
trustful
and but they will happen slightly later
so i prefer to do that whenever i have a
stock that lost you know around 50 even
more compared to its peak that lasts you
know 70 80 it's better to use the log
scale so this is what i'm using this is
how i get my trend line so let me put it
back how it was bam okay so
this is what happened we had this strong
website first thing like i said guys in
my previous video we were trading look
at the moving averages usually so first
we arrived on that trend line on the 3rd
of november we had this huge run up we
got rejected we closed below the trend
line and below the 230 level why 230
because it's the recent high so it's as
important as the trend line to me to
know if we are starting a new move up so
here we got rejected fine then we tested
it once twice three times and then we
corrected fair enough but look at what
happened we didn't even touch the moving
averages which was for me a bullish
signal that i i told you guys you know
whenever bears are not able to reach the
targets it's bullish you know so we had
some good signals here before then we
were grinding grinding higher and
suddenly this huge move up on friday i
checked the news i didn't see anything
so we might try to understand where this
is coming from and for me the reason is
the technicals i mean you know we had
this 200 basically 20 level that was
here resistance we went right through it
we also have the option expiry on that
day the november expiry
so the 220 strike was
there was some options there uh you can
check my previous videos it was not huge
it was not immense but still
whenever you go through a strike on the
expiry on the expiry day you're gonna
have this momentum created by option
market matches and this is what happened
here but to me the most important reason
to have this huge run up is that we went
through this resistance level just like
we did here guys whenever we go through
important levels especially if you have
some gamma you have this kind of
reactions and what triggered this move
up this is another question because we
need to have the move up
first to have then the momentum that is
starting and push higher so we know why
we push higher once we have started but
why did we start this is a good question
and i'm not sure i just give you my
feeling here is you know on the expiry
people just roll the options all right
if you have for example november 250
calls
you know that they're probably not gonna
finish in the money so you are wondering
should i roll it to december or to
january and if yes then on that day you
will close your november options
expiring and you will open a new option
on december or january which means that
basically you're gonna buy shares i mean
you're gonna buy calls
market makers are selling you calls and
they're gonna buy shares to hatch the
positions against you so this is the
reason why on those expiring day you
have sometimes a bigger volume than
usual and here i think it's a mix of
everything option expiry we went through
the 220 strike that was you know uh
where we had some kind of a substantial
position on november and uh december and
we had this roll so this is the
situation we went through the to so for
me the level was 220 roughly so we
closed above perfect very good do we
have energy so to know if we have energy
you can check bollinger bands rsi let's
do it okay we had energy here as you can
see the rsi was below around neutral and
we had this breakout at this level that
i i gave you guys by the way and then we
you can see the bollinger bands were
tighter and then we closed above the
upper bend so here the situation is
slightly different as you can see the
bollinger bands are wider and we arrive
on the rsi that is close to be
overbought you guys know that when the
rsi is overbought for example here it
was on the boat we still took
50 right so it's not a signal it's not a
bearish signal when you have another
boat rsi just means that
we are not in a setup when we are full
of energy then next thing we can say so
we have analyzed the energy by using
bollinger bands and rsi i get rid of the
bollinger bands bam
uh second thing do we have some
resistance close to us
yes we do we have the 230 resistance why
because it was the recent high let's
check if you had some reactions on this
250 move here
nothing clear all right so it was not
acting here a little bit okay almost 229
yeah this is valid so here one reaction
let me go into 15 minutes i'm frame i
just want to check if
it was used here yeah you can see here
little bits here yes okay so you can see
here the 200 to the level was
consolidating for one hour here we had
one reaction and here again one reaction
and here one reaction so basically on
the 15 minutes timeframe we have around
seven eight reactions in the past month
so it means this level is followed we
knew that but it's always good to
confirm it by checking really how
investors react close to this levels and
here you can see that it's a level that
buyers and sellers both use to enter or
exit some positions so it's an important
level that we need to close above
to look really good so we are looking
great guys okay let's be honest but we
are not looking perfect because we miss
a little bit of energy and we have a
resistance just on top of us so what is
my view as usual guys i'm gonna give you
my view you know i'm gonna give you two
scenarios my preferred scenario and um
the alternative scenario so both
scenarios are going to be bullish but my
preferred scenario is how to say it's
let's say it's a 50 50 but let's be
bullish and we're going to move higher
maybe correct a little bit you know and
move into five ways like this then
correct then go here and something like
that okay this is my bullish preferred
scenario all right is that we push
higher we find we need some at some
point to find some energy just look like
here we arrived strong but the second
day was bullish after this huge gap up
third day was bearish we need sometimes
to take back some energy so either we do
it right now or we're gonna do it
slightly later i don't think we can run
up to 350 without any pullback i mean
there's going to be at least one
pullback that can last one day or maybe
three days i don't know but at some
point we need to take back some energy
so in the bullish case most bullish case
we go right away to 250 then correct to
230 and then go higher just for you guys
to know so i'm personally involved in
this trade as most of you so i had a
position before but
let's say i add it up here
at
175 roughly so here i bought some calls
sold some puts
then here i swinged it a little bit and
here i just bought one little put and
what i'm gonna do with it so i'm still
it's basically reducing my position by
30 i'm not sacrificing any of my upside
performance i have calls and i keep it
because i don't want to sacrifice any of
that by selling a higher call which is
something that i might be doing later
but it's much too early to do that
um also we had a huge spike in
volatility i'm going to show you that
very soon but it's important so for this
reason buying calls right now is maybe a
bit risky but makes sense so my
preferred scenario yes is that we go
here in this case i would just sell my
put on this pullback
and probably buy more calls or do
something i don't know yet
in the alternative scenario which is
possible as well
is that we get rejected first re-test
the trend line but you guys know that
most of the time we have those retests
so we can expect to have it here
and then
we go higher you know and do a little
bit the same thing so i don't know 50
50.
of course we closed the day at the
highest level of the day so this is
bullish so that's why i'm rather
thinking we're gonna open higher on
monday but if we don't guys it's fine
and i'm personally going to use this
level either to sell my proof so for
sure to sell my put i'm going to sell my
put on the first pullback i see this
week even if it's higher i don't care to
lose a bit of premium and yeah so this
is what i think will happen this week
now let's have a look guys at the option
market so i'm already on it
and as you can see we monitor different
things here we are monitoring first
regular shot 12 percent didn't move
maybe i can find the next one right now
up i'm checking it with you guys i don't
know if the 30s
okay so the regular shot moved from 12
to 11 percent so roughly stable and the
synthetic shot is right now at six point
three percent okay so the gt seats is at
4.8 so it's rather stable we can see in
the past month we are between six and
five so we are already in an area where
shorts are under pressure where there is
tension in the markets where shorts need
to trade five daily volume to cover all
their short positions which is a lot so
we have this tension this is one more
reason probably we had some stop losses
activated here i didn't mention that but
it's the same thing
whenever you go through a breakout level
you have some buyers stepping in and you
have some sellers that cut the position
they have a stop loss just above so it's
probably a domino effect as well on the
stop losses that help to push the price
higher because we have a dtc at five so
shorts know they need to have a stop
loss somewhere because they can get
squeezed they're aware of this so this
at 4.8 and let's check the 950 strike we
were just above 4 million last time i
checked we are right now at 4.1
million shares equivalent on this level
it's absolutely insane
compared to everything we have on the
other strikes for example the biggest
one is at 300
and we have 1.4 million shares so we
have around three times more
options on the 950 strike than on the
300 strike by the way you can notice
that the biggest strike if i don't take
into account the 950 usually is close to
the money so the money is at 229 right
now so we should have it at 250 but you
can see the 250 strike we have around
700 000 equivalent shares whereas we
have 1.4 million shares on the 300
strike what does it tell us
it tells us guys that whenever we're
gonna go through this strike shorts are
gonna get squished okay it's gonna
amplify the move whenever we go through
300 so this is the reason why i believe
that
if we close above 230
we're gonna need to test the 250 level
that is the most recent high even if we
were there only 15 minutes or one hour
it's still the next resistance so maybe
here we're gonna have some kind of a
projection but here it's a no man's land
as you see guys i don't have any
resistance between 250 and 350 so i
believe that once we trade above
250
it's going to be very volatile
everything can happen but most likely
we're going to have this kind of bam
strong moves why because of the gamma
300 strike is huge and i'm pretty sure
it's gonna grow in the coming days so
one more thing i wanted to show you
quickly guys if you go on options and
you are wondering is it better to have
for example 240 calls
i'm on the january maturity or is it
better to have 300 calls it's a good
question and i'm
i'm personally having some 240 calls and
i was wondering should i roll it higher
all right should i get more leverage by
buying a 300 call instead and to know
what is better
you just
put the two strategies one against the
other so here i have my 240 call on the
gen 22 maturity for a premium of around
3 000 us dollars now if i sell it and i
buy the same amount of premium on the
300 strike i sell one call i can buy 1.5
so you cannot trade 1.5 but let's say
you have two then you need to buy three
basically you can buy 50 more 300 calls
than 240 calls for the same premium okay
should we do it first you check the
volatility you can see that the
volatility is 50 points higher on the
300 strike so you pay a higher premium
to get this option first thing so it's
not good in terms of volatility 15
points is not small it's quite a lot
so for those first reason it's better
not to do it then if you still want to
do it let's check the payoff of the
difference which is basically going to
tell you whenever you would have been
right to do it if it's positive it means
that the 300 call strategy once again
for the same premium is better and you
can see that we are positive
above so you take the blue trend line
the blue line which is the perfect
maturity so basically we start to be
positive above 180
so you would have been right to do it if
gamestop trades above
410 in january so it's uh it's not easy
to answer but i would personally keep my
240 call because i it's a better
volatility
and i would have been right to keep it
if we are below 410 so i would just make
a little bit less money for above but
you never know what's going to happen if
we close at 350
which is possible as well which is below
400 then you would have been right to
keep the 240 so to conclude on that it's
more conservative to have a lower strike
it gives you more flexibility to for
example buy boots or do whatever you
want but if you really believe we're
going to go to 800 right away which is
very possible as well and if you want to
play this scenario you can see that for
example whenever at 200
for example or even 300
you make 12 000 us dollars more by
having the 300 strike call so this is
the trade-off that you guys have once
again i personally prefer to have a
lower strike and then a bit swing it so
that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video i hope as well that
we're gonna see a crazy week on gme uh
this is pretty nice uh what is happening
right now we have the volumes we have
with the breakout we have the new high
we have everyone talking about it so
this is looking quite good to me so i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
gonna be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to show i'll
see you guys